you really need to hear this out because
it really changed my life and I hope it
changes yours it's been a massive shift
in the economy in 2022 and my investment
thesis has changed I've taken all my
cash out of Banks and I've put it
somewhere else that's both safer and
gets me a higher return the way you put
your money has to shift because the
economy has changed and at the very end
of this video I'll tell you my entire
investment strategy and what I have
shifted towards now I'm 33 years old and
I crossed 100 million dollars in net
worth last year and much to my dismay
there was no parade I'm still 2 000
times poorer than the richest man in the
world no songs written about me let's
talk most I have talked to many
billionaires to try and figure out what
my investment strategy was going to be
to get from 100 million to a billion
because the economy has changed things
are priced differently there's
inflationary pressures real estate is a
is hanging on by a thread crypto is
crashed stocks have crashed so before we
can get into the investing part you have
to understand what to actually do with
the cash itself while you wait to make
your moves what do you do with your cash
if you've ever heard Warren Buffett or
you heard people in the news say he has
x billion dollars in cash or cash
equivalents he doesn't actually have it
sitting in cash he has it sitting in
something else that's better and I'll
explain what that is in a second I'm
going to rewind and explain what
actually putting cash into bank account
means and why it's important in today's
environment so when you put cash into a
bank you're actually writing the bank
alone to then loan your money and get
something back people don't know this
but you actually are a creditor of the
bank so if a bank goes out of business
they owe you money now what happens is
the bank will do one of two things they
will either loan money to the government
by buying bonds now why do they do that
because the likelihood risk that the
government is going to be able to pay
them back extremely high why because
they can print the damn money and give
it back to them or they will loan it out
to people on mortgages and things like
that they loan the money out again and
they make more than they pay you and so
right now if you look at your account
they'll pay you between point one and
one percent annually on your money boo
that sucks they take your money for 0.1
percent a year and then they give it to
the government and the government gives
them four percent a year so they get 40
times what they pay you by giving the US
government money now here's what's most
important about debt when you loan
people money there are two factors one
is what are you going to get back which
is the interest rate and the second is
How likely are you going to get it the
interest rate is if you've loan someone
of money for a house and it's five
percent or whatever then if you put 100
Grand and you get five thousand back and
you get paid that for taking on risk now
this is what's crazy and I didn't
understand this when I was putting my
money in the bank if the bank goes under
you lose all your money outside of the
FDIC insured amount the FDIC right now
is completely bankrupt anyways and on
top of that if it exceeds that amount
you get stuck in the bankrupt company
whoop-dee-doo what if there were a
better alternative that was lower risk
and had higher returns I just learned
about this and the reason I always
ignored it was because it looked boring
and ugly what we decided to do before I
tell you the big investment strategy
that we've invested like the big money
into we decided to take that money and
buy U.S treasuries and you're like why
would they do that because I'm not
seeing treasuries as an investment
vehicle I'm seeing it as a bank account
who is more likely to go under Bank of
America United States government
Bank of America more likely to going who
pays me more Bank of America U.S
government
U.S government on top of that you can
take loans against treasuries for up to
80 percent of the value so if you get a
hundred thousand dollars in treasuries
and you get four thousand dollars a year
in interest I could take a loan for up
to eighty thousand dollars keep earning
my interest and then put it somewhere
else you're like why don't they talk
about this they are happy to take your
money and go make five percent on it and
pay you point one that's the business
why would they tell people my entire
structure of Investments has changed
over the last five years really last ten
years the first chunk of my life was SME
500 I put all my excess cash into
learning skills getting access to people
coaching mentorships workshops Etc
highest return investment I still have
ever made today number two once I had
more money than I could possibly
reinvest in courses and coaching and
whatnot I started applying it into the S
P 500 because that's what Uncle Warren
told me to do I figured if it worked for
him would work for me the third phase
came post sale all right so we sold
three companies last year I talked to a
bunch of different friends who were very
very wealthy and one of them is a very
good investor he outlined a strategy for
me they called a barbell strategy which
is I have stocks over here real estate
over here very little between and then I
just have my private equities of the
companies that I own so I'd make money
here and plowed into these two right
with basically nothing in between here's
the thing that you don't know in the
last two years I've maybe made five
Investments and those Investments
represent in total maybe 10 of the cash
that I have I didn't realize what the
problem was until I saw a video from
Dave Ramsey and before you cast judgment
you really need to hear this out because
it really changed my life and I hope it
changes yours so I was watching a video
where Graham Stefan was having Dave
Ramsey analyze his Investment Portfolio
and he said hey Dave don't you feel like
I'm over indexed on real estate 80 plus
percent of my net worth is in real
estate deals Dave Ramsey gave one of the
wisest responses that I've ever heard in
investing and it changed my life he said
well Graham if you put a big circle on
the table and I'm Loosely paraphrasing
and we had to say what percentage of
your knowledge is real estate versus
stocks and bonds and other stuff what
would you say it is he said oh well I
don't know 80 85 of what I know is
really about real estate
and he looked at him he was like well
then that's a perfect distribution for
you because it reflects your knowledge
if we were going to put a portfolio
together of your knowledge base it would
be 80 real estate 20 stocks maybe so
where you invest is what you know and so
then he went on to say I have talked to
many many billionaires probably far more
than I have he said I've learned two
things from them they don't do many
things and the things they pick are
things they understand and they do a lot
of them they find something that they
like and that they understand and that
they're good at and they do it a lot and
for whatever reason the combination of
understanding that in the circle this is
the slice of the pie that he knew and
that the people were the richest in the
world just pick one game or two games
they know really well and they do a ton
of those games is what changed my
perspective my takeaway was not oh I
should go have 85 percent of my
portfolio be real estate because 85 of
my knowledge on investing is not real
estate and the reason I wasn't able to
write checks for two years despite
having this theoretical barbell strategy
you know we had laid out with a friend
of mine who's awesome investing is that
that was his investment strategy was it
Alex's investment strategy what are the
things that I actually know it turns out
not a lot what I am good at is we're
very good at service based businesses
that is where I thrive if I just write
my money into deals there I could do
that with my eyes closed and so I had a
deal that came to me recently way bigger
than any real estate deal that I've ever
even thought about participating in I
just looked at the guy and I was like I
will write you an unlimited check how
much do you want I understand that
business this is something that I've
spent my entire life doing and this is a
Warren Buffett quote it's only risky if
you don't know what you're doing and so
if you don't know what you're doing the
reason he gives the S P 500 advice is
that you don't know what you're doing so
just put it into 500 companies and
you'll be okay but where you get the
outsized returns is playing in a game
where you have an unfair Advantage where
you know more than everybody else does
now I'm at a point where I feel pretty
comfortable writing sizable checks into
actual private deals I'm actually pretty
risk-averse but in this world I know the
risks and so I can name them and I can
know where to look for them and I'm like
oh this is appropriate risky if you
don't know what you're doing step one
invest in you step two invest access in
indexes and then when you feel like
you're good enough at your main game
then you have the stockpile and you can
deploy it and then that starts the
compounding machine my investment
strategy after all of this time has gone
completely back to my business strategy
which is singular Focus do the things
you know do more do it better and keep
doing that for an extended period of
time and it would be unreasonable that
you don't win